good morning John a kind of remarkable
skill but I've never talked about here
on vlogbrothers in a lifetime of work to
master it it requires a truly
mesmerizing amount of muscle control in
my mouth and throat and abdomen can be
beautiful it can be terrifying depending
on my mood and only one out of every
eight point seven million species on
earth can do it possibly the most
remarkable thing I am capable of doing I
am doing right now talking words have
noises come out of my mouth and I direct
them at people and then the people are
like yeah I'll meet you at Buffalo Wild
Wings at 7:00 it's a miracle and it's
kind of a miracle that we don't notice
how remarkable this ability is and we
have words for everything just but look
around this is a book it's called a book
but uh there's more words here this is
paper and this is cardstock this is
embossed it's an emboss to cover this is
a spine there's blurbs on Erb blurb is a
word this is a llama head stitched onto
the body of an elephant there's a word
for that this thing you put it around
neck there's a word for it lanyard who
came what why you have words for words
nouns and verbs and adjectives and
adverbs and words for words that mean
the same things as other words and words
for things that are the opposite meaning
of other words you have so many words
that there are some words that mean the
opposite of themselves inflammable
means both very easy to catch on fire
and very hard to catch on fire
penguin means both cheerful and
bloodthirsty good news though we have a
word for when words mean the opposite of
the thing that they mean but if we
didn't have a word for it there would
still be a word for it because we have a
word for when there isn't a word for a
thing yeah take some time to think about
that it is so unusual to encounter a
situation in which you don't have a word
for a thing that most people don't even
know that there is a word for when the
thing doesn't have a word for it you
have a word for the best possible word
to use in any given situation which
means that if you need the best possible
word to describe the best possible word
it describes itself in fact there are a
number of words that describe themselves
a noun is a noun cutesy
sounds kind of adorable magniloquent
means grandiose and also sounds
grandiose polysyllabic is polysyllabic
unhyphenated is unhyphenated and at one
point the word coined was coined and you
will not probably be surprised to find
that there is a word for words that
describe them
and that word is autological and it is
also autological in that it describes
itself but that's not the hard part
though the hard part is that autological
has an antonym which is heterological
and heterological doesn't describe
itself because it doesn't describe
itself but it does describe itself
because it's so it's Auto logic but it's
not Auto lot it's not opt illogical
because it's heterological so if federal
but if it is heterological that it is
auto logic luckily we got a word for
that too
last year john and i conducted a census
of nerdfighteria because we wanted to
know more about this community and we
wanted this community to know more about
itself also it helps us decide what to
focus our time on where we might go on
tour what new shows to be thinking about
do a general goal of the census is to
make nerdfighteria a better place so if
you have time and it does take some time
like 10 to 30 minutes it's not an
insignificant little survey there are
some real questions on it we really want
you to answer then check out the link in
the description and fill out the census
we will be very thankful and they will
be making this community better also in
the doobly-doo there's a link to
nerdfighteria com where you can sign up
for a weekly newsletter which you should
do because it will keep you informed on
all sorts of amazing things going on in
the world and the list of nerdfighter
events that are happening all over the
world that you can participate in thank
you all for being a part of this
community and for putting up with me
being confused about words John I'll see
you on Tuesday
Grenn mad magniloquent from
grandiloquent Grendel it possible word
then get dis to tuck ha ha ha
this is oh that word is Otto drum rattle